ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen micro
fällt meine lieben freunde ich befinde
mich gerade auf dem balkon unseres in
der letzten folge gebauten baumhauses da
habe ich sehr viel positives feedback
von euch bekommen dafür wollte ich mich
einfach mal bedanken das freut mich sehr
dass euch das baumhaus gefällt von außen
können uns in apparate ja auch noch mal
anschauen den finde ich echt richtig süß
[Musik]
ich drück nix degas und heute meine
lieben freunde kommen wir auch endlich
zu dem thema worauf wir alle gewartet
haben
das machen wir eine andere folge keine
ahnung warum ich mich darüber gefreut
das wird ja heute das wirklich mit
abstand langweiligste video des
kompletten projektes von daher wenn ihr
auch schade schein tut mir leid wenn ihr
eher auf action steht dann schaltet in
der nächsten folge einer werden wir
nämlich in die hölle gehen
das zweite mal diese folge kommt morgen
schon online wir haben ja auch überhaupt
keine sortierung in unseren kisten und
so das werde ich denke ich in der
übernächsten folge machen gefordert sind
sogar noch unsere ganzen ärzte drin aber
ja eigentlich sinnvollen wir starten mit
der insel reparatur meine lieben freunde
und dafür nehme ich mir eine menge
sandstein mit um den ganzen kram den ich
nicht mehr brauche bruchstein an die
sieht granit die og
das gibt sie alles bescheide information
erst einmal würde ich sagen starten wir
hier vorne unter unserem haus denn wenn
ich jetzt hier beispielsweise einfach
mal einen blog wegnehme seht ihr schon
oh gott da geht es ordentlich ab das
wird glaube ich noch ziemlich lange
folge heute von daher habe ich unter
meinem letzten video eine menge
kommentare geschrien schottet eine menge
fragen eine menge anregungen mir
ausgesucht über die ich heute so ein
bisschen quatschen könnte und ich würde
sagen wir fangen direkt an mit diesem
kommentar frage für die insel reparatur
folge wann kommt die insel reparatur
folge ja ich weiß
es tut mir auch leid ich habe die insel
reparatur folge einfach seit wochen vor
mir hergeschoben weil das wirklich mit
abstand die langweiligste folge heute
wird das tut mir leid dass sozusagen wie
bereits gesagt wenn ihr action wollt
dann schaltet morgen einen da gehen wir
wieder in die hölle aber heute müssen
wir wirklich einfach die alle
was ein bisschen zu bauen weil ich halt
nicht möchte dass sie irgendwo
runtergefallen und dann in seiner fetten
höhle landen
ich habe bisher nur dass hier zugebaut
dementsprechend brauchen wir noch
deutlich mehr ressourcen wir gehen jetzt
erst mal unter dem wir haben hier unten
so einen kleinen gang wo wir dann gut so
ein bisschen strip meiden können
vielleicht zu kriegen wir ja auch
irgendwie diamanten oder noch ein paar
ärzte das wäre eigentlich auch ganz cool
aber ich will mich jetzt nicht die ganze
zeit von meinem kopf ist ein generator
darstellen würde allerdings sagen dass
wir der stelle auch direkt mit der
nächsten frage weiter machen wo waren
das hirn dass anni hat geschrieben du
könntest darüber reden wie sich dein
youtube-kanal aufgebaut hat denke das
könnte spannend sein ich habe ehrlich
gesagt einfach mit youtube videos
angefangen weil ich damals die videos
vom raum so cool fanden und er hat
damals minecraft aufgenommen dann dachte
ich mir das kann ja nicht so schwer sein
das mache ich jetzt auch einfach mal und
zwar extrem schwer eine menge tipps
bekommen ich habe spaß dran damit zwar
die ersten jahre überhaupt kein geld
verdient aber ich hatte einfach spaß
daran und ich glaube das ist das
wichtigste auf youtube larissa fragt
welche stadt in deutschland würdest du
gerne mal sehen in der du noch nicht
warst also die städte in deutschland die
ich warum es hier
ist das war ja das ist gold ist dass wir
haben ja man ich gehe jetzt einfach mal
nach oben eine glücks spitzhacke holt er
das sah echt wahnsinn wir meinen darum
weil ich koppel stones haben will und
was finden wir die ammann
das ist so geil diese map ich feiere to
normal aber auf deine frage einzugehen
larissa die städte die ich cool finden
den weicher selbstverständlich schon
weil ich das halt prüfen und deswegen
auch gerne dahin gefahren wenn herr
schwein wie geld ja wie geht's sorry
eine stadt in die ich auf jeden fall
gern mal reisen würde wäre raus
baden baden ist jetzt nicht so eine
weltmetropole aber man hört ziemlich
viel über über baden waren das ist nicht
geil sein sollte würde allerdings sagen
wir machen ja gerade mit der nächsten
frage und zwar kommt die von lulu und
zwar hat sie gefragt wie bist du darauf
gekommen dass die tiere villiger und so
weiter reden können ich habe mir da
wirklich nicht viel bei gedacht sondern
halt einfach hey die tiere in minecraft
die gucken einen halt häufig an wenn man
da irgendwie mit denen redet und so
weiter und so fort das könnte ja
vielleicht ganz lustig sein wenn ich
dann einfach was über dem kopf schreiber
dass das aber so gut bei euch ankommt
hätte ich wirklich niemals gedacht von
daher nochmal da auch danke für euren
support ich weiß ich sage viel zu häufig
danke für euren support aber es ist auch
einfach nicht selbstverständlich meine
frage wäre wie viele inseln du um die
hauptinsel bisher geplant hast also tier
insel fichten insel iz ehrlich gesagt
habe ich mir bisher noch gar keine
richtigen gedanken drüber gemacht das
einzige was ich weiß ist dass um
darunter ist direkt lava ok dann
bräuchte mal ganz kurz ab er ist jetzt
zwar ein bisschen dunkel aber ich hoffe
man kann es trotzdem sind erkennen
schauen wir mal wie viele diamanten
rausbekommen hier vorne sogar noch einen
diamanten
ich ertrinke
überhaupt nicht gedacht dass die
unterwasserwelt gas
ja das leben einfach weg ehrlich gesagt
hab ich mir darüber noch gar keine
richtigen gedanken gemacht ich überlege
mir das immer von folge zu folge wie ich
vorgehen und habe jetzt keinen
perspektivischen klaren wie das projekt
um eine insel in drei wochen aufgebaut
sein sollte dann scheide ich mal von
folge zu folge allerdings finde ich den
gedanken ganz cool dass alles so ein
bisschen so wie die malediven also ganz
viele kleine was das also einfach ganz
ganz viele kleine inseln und dann kann
man immer von insel zu insel rüber und
so weiter und so fort ich muss übrigens
wieder nach oben weil ich keine fackeln
mehr haben meine frage kannst du mal
richtig richtig lange folgen machen so
welche die 30 bis 40 minuten lang gehen
das ist tatsächlich der kommentar den
ich am meisten leser unter meinen videos
und da muss ich leider so ernüchternd
antworten dass das nicht passieren wird
die sache ist dass ich schon mit meinem
upload
also erstmal nämlich ein schild in die
hand aber
[Musik]
habe ich an ihm vorbei
er ist nicht in die ich bin einfach der
profite gab die sache ist dass ich an
jedem video erst mal in der vorbereitung
in meiner test welt um zu gucken ob
alles so klappt wenn ich sachen bau et
cetera pp dafür brauche ich mehrere
stunden dann für die aufnahme brauche
ich auch meistens so zwei stunden und
dann noch mal mit dem schnitt auch
nochmal so fünf stunden wegen den ganzen
texteinblendungen für die tiere um so
das dauert ein bisschen und das ist halt
alles mit keyframe ziemlich anstrengend
deswegen ist es aktuell nicht möglich
wenn ich irgendwann katar haben oder so
dann wenn ich irgendwann mal in katar
habe sagte kater haben sollte dann
sollte das eigentlich machbar sein dass
die folgen länger gehen allerdings
möchte ich keinen partner haben weil ich
finde dass dieses projekt auch davon
lebt dass ich mir komm runter den rasen
gibt kommen runter wenn du dich traust
komm runter wäre tot
ich möchte keinen kassa und viele
youtuber sagen wir da immer so haye
könnte seine zeit so viel produktiver
nutzen wenn lukas blabla aber mir macht
schneiden spaß auch wenn ich sehr
anstrengend ist und ich finde das
projekt lebt auch davon ich glaube es
wäre nicht so cool wenn in katar das
machen würde weil er nie direkt komplett
meinen humor und so weiter und so fort
treffen würde lilly hat gefragt welche
geschichte findest du von deinem leben
sehr lustig komisch oder emotional dass
ich generell ein bisschen komisch lustig
beziehungsweise emotionaler meinem
lieben findet bzw an mir selber meinem
charakter finde ist dass ich denke dass
alles irgendwie gefühle hat also auch
wenn es ein stuhl ist oder irgendwie so
da irgendwie materieller gegenstand oder
so will ich mich immer ihm gegenüber
korrekt verhalten so kommen dass jetzt
vielleicht bringt aber ich würde jetzt
niemals ein stuhl irgendwie dort gegen
den tisch dann allerdings machen wir
dann würde ich mich danach beim sprühen
entschuldigen vinci zufrieden wenn du
einen tag lang das leben mit irgendwem
tauschen könntest wer wäre es eigentlich
bin ich mit meinen leuten gefallen
[Musik]
das kannst du dir nicht ausdenken
ich bin doch zurückgelaufen die gaben
der redstone das kannst du dir nicht
ausdenken das ist unfassbar ich sehe
jetzt wieder alle kommentare vor der
chinesin total der liegt über dem gesetz
der dax gemacht kommen geht weg geht weg
denn irgendwann den sieg bekommt und den
kriegt irgendwann mal dann könnt ihr
sehen dass hier nichts geschieht ist das
ist ja geisteskrank die kripo die ich
immer so hasse auf einmal geben die mir
hier diamanten dk was ist denn spaßig um
eine spitzhacke weg um auf die frage ein
zu denen ich bin eigentlich relativ
happy mit meinem leben und es ist jetzt
nicht so dass ich sage puh hat guck mal
dem geht es viel besser und dann möchte
ich unbedingt tauschen ich bin total
happy über meine familie acht jahren
haben wir haben drei stück abgebaut
ich bin total happy weil meine familie
und will eigentlich ungern mein leben
tauschen
deswegen steht das kann ich eigentlich
nicht zur debatte wenn ich allerdings
müsste dann wäre es glaube ich nie post
in honolulu als frage beziehungsweise
eher kleines thema für die insel
reparatur mich würde mal interessieren
ob die erfahrungen damit hast
beziehungsweise hat ist und so weiter
außerdem finde ich es spannend zu hören
ob so richtige hater hast die ich dann
wirklich irgendwie auf der straße wenn
sie dich erkenn dorf ansprechen oder ob
es sogar leute gibt die rausgefunden
haben wo du wohnst und ich damit dort
irgendwie stören oder ähnliches danke
für deine frage mara ich finde die
wirklich sehr sehr cool und solche
fragen fühle ich auch deutlich mehr als
beispielsweise irgendwie was ist deine
lieblings pizza oder irgendwie sowas ich
glaube dass es beim thema mobbing keine
zwei meinungen geben sollte weil mobbing
ist einfach scheiße punkt aus ende und
ich habe mich ja auch gegen mobbing
schon oft stark gemacht in kampagnen und
so weiter und so fort und obwohl ich nie
zum glück nie erfahrungen mit mobbing
machen musste kann ich mich wirklich da
hinein versetzen menschen und kann mir
vorstellen wie schlimm es ist wenn man
gemobbt wird
was ich euch einfach nur sagen kann
falls sie darunter leiden solltet ist es
hält nicht für immer an
und bei mir ist es zum beispiel auch so
ich hab nur noch mit ganz ganz wenigen
leuten von damals zu tun ich war 140 mit
140 leuten in einer stufe auf dem
gymnasium von denen mit denen also habe
ich noch mit mit fünf leute oder so was
zu tun
also man hat wirklich mit mobbing ich
hab eine hütte gefunden ich habe leute 2
wächst hier
ich sagte er war gar nix mehr zu um das
thema kurz zum ende zu bringen ist es
immer licht am ende des tunnels und ihr
solltet euch von leuten die es ihre
hauptaufgabe machen anderen leuten
schaden zuzufügen überhaupt nicht
irgendwas sagen lassen und mit den
eltern die andere sache die du mich
gefragt hat es mara ich hatte
tatsächlich noch nie jemanden auf der
stadtbahn inventars post hier schon
wieder ich habe noch nie jemanden auf
der straße getroffen der mich dann
wirklich beleidigt hat oder irgendwie
doof an gemacht hat oder so also ich
glaube die meisten leute die helfen
machen das ja auch mit irgendwelchen
anonym accounts oder irgendwie so und
die haben dann in real life
wahrscheinlich einfach nicht in meinem
das auch so zu sagen deswegen lass dir
nicht sagen erst recht nicht von
cybermobbing leuten das ist noch
deutlich weiter als wenn leute das sind
echt machen das ist wirklich unfassbar
und ich finde es auch gut dass da hat
deutschland im nächsten jahr ein
bisschen durchgreifen will im internet
und so leute dass ich wirklich stalker
hatte das ist schon relativ häufig
passiert also ich hatte auch hier in
hamburg schon oft leute in der
tiefgarage wenn mein auto zerkratzt oder
in den briefkasten gesteckt in köln
hatte im treppenhaus stehen das sind
einfach die schattenseiten damit muss
man leben und da berichte ich zwar nie
drüber und das bringt natürlich auf aber
dafür hat es doch ganz ganz viele
vorteile mein leben hier und ich möchte
mich überhaupt nicht darüber beschweren
frage zur insel reparatur welches video
format von deinen magst du am meisten ps
liebe deine videos ich glaube dass
checkt man relativ schnell wenn man sich
mal einen kanal aktuell anschaut
momentan macht mir einfach dieses
minecraft projekt extrem viel spaß weil
das ja auch so ein community ding
irgendwie es ist nicht einfach nur mein
projekt und ich habe mir meine welt und
ende sondern es ist unsere welt und wir
alle machen dieses projekt zu dem was es
ist und deswegen feiere ich das am
meisten was das schmeiße ich denn jetzt
mal hierhin ich ich muss wieder nach
oben gehen um mich aus lärm frage für
die insel reparatur folge wird das
projekt später enden und es kommen neue
projekte oder nur dass das kann ich dir
ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht richtig
beantworten wie ich ja vorhin schon
gesagt habe plane ich hier wirklich nur
von folge zu folge also klar ich habe
eine notiz wo ich so idee
drinnen festhaltung mit ein bisschen
überlegen okay das hier ist jetzt eher
so eine insel reparatur folgende ein
bisschen ruhigere folge dann wird die
nächste folge morgen so ein bisschen
krasser wir gehen in die höhle und sowas
plan ich natürlich an die gottheit
erhaltene artefakte wegen hier bekommt
was sich allerdings natürlich nicht
plane ist hey das projekt soll jetzt
genau 50 folgen lang gehen oder nach 100
folgen fängt staffel zwei jahren oder so
ich möchte das einfach so lange machen
wie es mir spaß macht und deswegen
keinen spaß mehr mache dann mach ich
halt nicht mehr dann wird wieder was
anderes kommen vielleicht aber aktuell
macht mir das halt spaß und das ist
einfach mein youtube kanal so ich mache
das immer worauf ich bock habe und ich
glaube es gibt keinen kanal in youtube
deutschland der so viele verschiedene
sachen macht wie ich oder so viele
verschiedene sachen schon gemacht hat
also ich hab ja blogs gemacht hat zeigt
wie actions gaming alles mögliche
challenges und jetzt gerade das ist halt
minecraft was mir am meisten spaß macht
lulu möchte wissen was der größte flex
in meinem leben ist das ja mit meinem
rechten ohr wackeln hättest du je
gedacht dass wir dieses projekt so hart
feiern ganz einfache antwort auf gar
keinen fall
ich halte nie gedacht dass minecraft
noch so viele leute begeistert und ich
habe das projekt ja auch gestartet und
die ersten folgen liefen auch überhaupt
nicht gut also klar da waren
hunderttausende aufrufe logisch das ist
richtig geil und da bin ich auch richtig
froh drüber und stolz drauf und so lange
sie das 110 voller leute gucken ist es
für mich ein voller erfolg aber es war
wirklich so dass die erste folge im
vergleich zu meinen anderen videos nicht
so krass abgängen und das kam wirklich
erst mit der zeit und mittlerweile ist
jedes neue video was sich irgendwie
hochladen oder fast jedes video in den
deutschen youtube trends als wenn ich
die schon irgendwie abonniert hätte oder
so und da freue ich mich extrem darüber
und ich kann mir das auch einfach nicht
erklären ich sehe auch anhand der
bewertungen die waren noch nie so gut in
meinem ganzen youtube laufbahn dingsbums
hatte ich solche kranken bewertungen
also ich glaube man sollte wirklich
einfach das machen worauf man bock hat
und dann hat man auch erfolg wenn du in
ein land fliegen könnte ist halt ohne
diese ganze situation welches wäre es
dann ich glaube wenn ich jetzt in
irgendeinem land reisen dürfte ganz
abseits von corona und so weiter und so
fort wäre das island spiel was machst du
da unten
schillig das klingt jetzt vielleicht ein
bisschen altmodisch aber ich hätte
richtig lust mal in island einfach
wandern zu gehen und ich habe damals
einen roadtrip mit max gemacht durch
wales um das war mit der coolste urlaub
den ich je hatte weil wir einfach in
wales rumgefahren sind mit dem autos
waren wunderschöne landschaften und mich
kannst du mit so was wirklich begeistern
ich bin auch ein riesiger naturdoku fan
und klar ich freue mich auch mal wieder
nach ibiza zu fliegen und bisschen party
zu machen und in der sonne zu liegen
aber wenn ich mich jetzt entscheiden
müsste dann auf jeden fall island für
die insel reparatur folge wie viele
crashs hattest du jetzt eigentlich schon
die frage kann ich dir wirklich nicht
richtig beantworten klar wenn man optik
noch mehr unterwegs ist oder auf
instagram entdecken dann sieht man halt
auch mal mädels wo ich mir denke die
jetzt hier werde wohl der komplette
wahres gesicht lecken aber wie viele
crashs sich insgesamt schon hatte keine
nicht sagen 2000 frage für die nächste
folge warum hast du mit youtube
angefangen liebe dieses projekt erst mal
danke für dein kompliment hanni ich
finde es immer wieder so unfassbar
komisch bis zu sehen wenn leute mehrfach
schreiben bei euch liebe dass unser
letztes hat mir geschrieben ich gucke
die folgen oder mit meiner ganzen
familie abends wo ich mir dann einfach
so denken wort warum stehst dich den
grund warum ich mit youtube angefangen
habe habe ich ja bereits vor ein paar
minuten in dieser folge hier gesagt und
zwar weil das ganz einfach krank er hat
dann auch der ja ich hab schon wieder
sowas entdeckt hier was ist dein
lieblings chips oder pringles geschmack
ganz simple frage deswegen vor mir eine
ganz simple antwort prompt ships western
style die feier ich wirklich extrem sind
vielleicht ein bisschen zu intensiv für
den ein oder anderen aber ich finde
eigentlich ganz cool und welche ich auch
noch ganz neues findet die sind auch ein
bisschen weniger ungesund das sind die
linsen chips paprika die sind richtig
wild keine bezahlte werbung trage für
das nächste video hast du irgendein
großes ziel jetzt in deinem leben oder
einen großen wunsch findet sich sehr
sympathisch danke für die frage lara und
auch danke dir für das kompliment die
sache ist dass ich früher wirklich
krasse ziele hatte also beispielsweise
hey ich möchte eigentum haben ich möchte
mir eine eigene wohnung kaufen ich
möchte das hab ich da rausgekommen dass
sich auf einfach atmen kann also früher
hatte ich wirklich riesige materielle
ziele in die richtung hey eigene wohnung
und finanzielle unabhängigkeit
und ein cooles auto und coole klamotten
und eine pulle uhr und so was alles
geben mal mit der zeit habe ich dann
aber gemerkt als ich mir die ziele
erfüllt habe und mir die die wünsche
erfüllt habe und die träume erfüllt habe
dass ein dass nicht zu einem besseren
menschen macht man wird nicht
glücklicher halt nur weil man materielle
dinge besitzt und das finde ich sehr
wichtig euch einfach auch mit zu geben
also eifert nicht irgendwelchen leuten
hinterher nur weil sie jetzt vielleicht
viel geld haben klar
dann gehen einige probleme wirklich weg
aber viele neue probleme kommen auch als
man wird nicht glücklicher nur weil man
materielle dinge hat und das habe ich in
dem sommer dieses letzten jahres
realisiert wo ich den langen youtube
hause gemacht habe wo ich so ein
bisschen die motivation verloren habe
und die ist jetzt wieder gekommen auch
mit diesem microsoft project weil ich
einfach das machen worauf ich bock habe
und deswegen ist mein großes
übergeordnetes ziel aktuell liebe lada
einfach glücklich sein und einfach
glücklich sein spaß an allem haben was
man macht wenn jemand in dein haus
einbricht und du dich in einem raum
deiner wohnung für sagen wir mal 20
stunden fragt nicht wieso einschließen
müsse desto besser wäre es du kannst
auch einen raum wählen indem man sich
eigentlich nicht einschließen kann
brauche ich habe keine ahnung wie du auf
die frage kommst und ich werde sich auch
nicht beantworten weil das wird gar
keinen sinn machen wenn jetzt gegen
einbrecher die gerade zukunft dann weiß
ich wo ich mich dann verstecke das ist
ein bisschen kontraproduktiv frage für
die insel reparatur folge welches seiner
tiere außer blumen marx bzw möchtest du
am liebsten das mag jetzt vielleicht ein
bisschen blöd klingen weil das jetzt
kein einzelnes tier ist oder kein
einzelner villiger whatever allerdings
wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste sind es
tatsächlich die pilzköpfe die ich ja vor
einigen folgen getötet habe und da habe
ich wirklich im video eine kleine träne
verdrücken müssen als die ganzen kinder
getötet habe wohl als ich im schnitt
dann über die pilz chor noch hin
geschrieben habt bitte nicht und ich
habe diese traurige musik von wegen es
tut mir leid und so auf englisch und so
alles als das darüber gepackt hatte habe
ich auch noch mal eine träne verdrückt
also das sind tatsächlich die die ich am
meisten mochte weil sie mir halt nichts
getan haben und ich sie einfach alle
getötet haben aber ich musste es tun
für das leder aber sonst würde ich sagen
das schweinchen oder also ganz hinten
auf jeden fall das schaf hattest du
schon mal ein paranormales erlebnis wenn
ja welches erzähler es uns bitte ich
liebe solche geschichten vera da muss
ich dich leider enttäuschen ich glaube
nicht an irgendwelche paranormalen dinge
ich glaube nicht an geister und kann
ahnung was ist es ein bisschen doof dass
ich dann eigentlich an gott glaube wenn
ich eigentlich so wissenschaftlich an
solche ganzen sachen rangehen allerdings
glaube ich eigentlich nicht an
irgendwelche sachen was komisches was
immer passiert ist es dass ich
eigentlich mich ins bett gelegt habe und
die tür zugemacht haben dann lag ich im
bett und am nächsten morgen kam ich halt
auf meinem bett ross und die tür war
sperrangelweit offen
und da meine ich nicht ich habe die tür
angelehnt und ich einen entzug ist
aufgegangen sein ich hab sie wirklich
zugemacht und abgeschlossen was ist
eines der lustigsten ereignisse aus
seiner schulzeit greta das wusstest du
wenn du mein buch gelesen
hallo mein name ist luca ein buch was
meine mutter und ich über mein leben
geschrieben haben wenn ihr euch den fans
schenken allerdings nicht bei amazon
bestellen wollt dann kann ich euch das
jetzt hier auch noch mal ganz kurz
erklären und zwar habe ich ein
wettrennen gemacht mit einem kollegen
bei uns damals auf dem pausenhof von der
grundschule und wir hatten bzw
habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch vor den
schultüren so gta damit man als eine
schule drauf ausschlagen kann damit
nicht den ganzen dreck mit nach drinnen
trägt und das war halt im winter und das
war halt alles ein bisschen kitschig
wenn wir das wettrennen gemacht bist du
der tür und ich bin halt auf diesem
gitter aus gerutscht weil das so glatt
war und bin mit meinem knie frontal in
die scheibe von der schultür rein
gekracht und dann brauchte die
schultüren eine neue scheibe und keiner
konnte den unterricht gehen wir da alles
voll mit scherben lag und das war
ziemlich peinlich
was war das ist gehört dass von hier
irgendwo was für ein geräusch schreibt
mir das gerne in die kommentare ich will
mich hier auf jeden fall ich weiß nicht
ob da jetzt irgendwie ankommt und mir
irgendwas cloud oder monster wider oder
irgendwie so aber die kohle fordern eben
nur ganz kurz mit ich würde allerdings
sagen dass wir das meinen an der stelle
jetzt auch beenden und er wird ja auch
immer im inventar ich habe 66 steine in
meinem inventar habe ich generell noch
ein bisschen mehr damit werde ich jetzt
mal so ein bisschen insel reparatur
betreiben ich bin der aufnahme schon bei
zwei stunden und bin ja auch ordentlich
voran gekommen was das meinen angeht ich
glaube wir bräuchten so war vielleicht
irgendwann mal eine zweite insel
reparatur folge allerdings will ich
sagen machen wie weiter mit der nächsten
frage und zwar fragt die liebe anna wie
lange verbringst du zurzeit um für uns
videos zu schneiden habe ich glaube ich
zu beginn schon so ein bisschen gesagt
es kommt so ein bisschen drauf an wie
aufwendig die folge zum beispiel bei
sowas hier da steckt in der vorbereitung
eigentlich fast gar keine zeit klar ich
muss dir die ganzen kommentare
raussuchen und so aber das dauert jetzt
nicht sagen dass dort gleich eine halbe
stunde
aber wenn es so um folgen geht wie
beispielsweise hey ich baue im baumhaus
oder ich brauche keine ahnung was dann
dauert die vorbereitung hat erstmals ein
paar stündchen und dann halt die
aufnahme meistens so zwei stunden dann
der schnitt noch mal so fünf stunden
aber es macht mir spaß und ich
ja der letzte sein der sich jemals über
schnitt beschweren wird kannst du uns
mal bitte dienst ead zeigen zusammen mit
dem kommentar dass sich doch bitte
längere folgen hochladen soll ist das
wirklich das was am meisten unter meine
videos geschrieben wird ich kann das auf
jeden fall nachvollziehen meine welt ist
extrem geil ich feiere die übertrieben
und man findet sie doch nirgendwo im
internet weil ich die welt hat einfach
so random er stellte arbeitet das
projekt gestartet habe deswegen möchte
ich das ganze auch noch ein bisschen
geheim halten weil ich halt einfach
nicht gespeichert werden möchte und dass
leute und das weiß ich wenn ich den
speed raus hat mir direkt schreiben
helga guck mal ich bin da und dahin
gefahren dass eine schatzkarte duca guck
mal da ist eine kranke höhle luca wenn
du uns enden möchte ist dass es da vorne
an der stelle das was möchte ich einfach
nicht ich möchte nicht den spaß nehmen
lassen so dumm dass jetzt vielleicht
klingen mag auch wenn es mich halt
weiter bringen wenn ihr mir dann hälfte
und so aber der zieht kommt vielleicht
bei folge 100 oder irgendwie so und das
war allerdings auch schon die letzte
frage die ich mir vor ausgesucht habe
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass wir hier
solange amrum einem sind und dass die
höhe hier wirklich so riesig sind die
wir hinterlassen haben allerdings können
wir das hier auf jeden fall jetzt erst
mal füllen mit den materialien die wir
uns in der höhle zusammen gesucht haben
also ich hoffe schon euch hat die insel
reparatur folge vielleicht so ein
bisschen gefallen wenn ihr jetzt immer
noch dran sein sollte dann schreibt man
in die kommentare
welches euer lieblings biom in minecraft
ist es würde mich jetzt echt mal
interessieren wer von euch solange beim
video daran dass ich jetzt hier fordern
und was bringt denn so ein bisschen erde
dann sieht man das nicht hier drunter
ist auf jeden fall jetzt kein hohlraum
mehr was ich auf jeden fall noch
schaffen möchte ist hier vorne an der
ecke moment hat
ich weiß nicht was wirst du mit dem
knochenmann
naja ich hier vorne muss mich auf jeden
fall auch noch ein bisschen hin zur
reparatur betreiben ich weiß nicht mehr
genau wo das hier war doch hier sind wir
schon wieder in der was ist so riesig
hier unten stimmen fällt auf dass sich
dass sie alle schon zugemacht habe als
ich in der time selbst vor ein paar
folgen das hier gemacht habe warte dass
ihr könnt ich mal blumen bringen was ich
mir ganz kurz die stocker dahin das
könnte ich bei dir auf jeden fall ein
bisschen verfüttern und ein bisschen
fleisch zu essen das habe ich nicht
vergessen dass ich das ja schon alles
zugemacht habe das eigentlich ganz gut
so wenn ihr mal ganz kurz das fleisch
hatten ziel hin können das dann balu
geben und hat ein bisschen was essen
was wir aber auf jeden fall dann machen
können ist er ganz kurz in dem bereich
wo die höhle ist ein starker hier vorne
indem wir mit die nehmen wir dient was
ich hier in dem bereich der höhle können
jetzt auch mal bis hin zu bauen hier
vorne da wo das skelett ja von
aufgetreten ist damit es einfach auch
hier so ein bisschen zu gebauter ist ich
hab total vergessen was ich gerade sagen
wollte ich setze mir ganz gut zu fackeln
dass es für euch ein bisschen
entspannter zum zuschauen dass sie würde
ich sagen wo ich noch zu was ist da kann
ich mich ja gar nicht dran
denn hier alles gibt und hier auch noch
alles zugang kann ich mich erstmal
wieder aufbauen und diese ecke dann auf
jeden fall schonmal zugebaut er ist halt
der menge dann runter gefallen ich weiß
nicht ob wir jetzt so ein kleines land
rutscht von unserem strand haben dann
möchte ich übrigens auch noch ein
bisschen was bauen so eine strandliege
und so weiter und so fort bzw wenn wir
in das ganze malediven dinge so ein
bisschen wenn wir damit anfangen mit den
ganzen kleinen inselchen und so dann
möchte ich da auf jeden fall so eine
kleine party insel machen eine kleine
strand insel und so das finde ich auf
jeden fall ganz cool und den sieg noch
hier vorne hin dass das ja zu ihre ich
war fast eine stunde und in der höhle am
meinen klar wir haben auch eine menge
ernst und so gefunden aber trotzdem habe
ich jetzt nur so ein bisschen hier
hingekriegt von der insel reparatur
ich wollte eigentlich komplette höhle
nachzubauen aber zumindest haben wir das
hier dann erst mal so ein bisschen hier
für ordnung gesorgt damit jetzt nicht so
krass viele monster auftreten aus den
ecken so zeigt das ist eigentlich alles
was ihr materialien habe um hier alles
mal so ein bisschen zu bauen also die
ganzen der ganze bereich als zu sollte
zumindest erstmal nichts mehr spornen
hoffentlich unten könnte ich noch eine
fackel ersetzen damit dass auch ein
bisschen heller noch ist ich gehe jetzt
mal hoch und schau mal ganz kurz ob
hinten am strand etwas abgerutscht ist
von dem dingens von dem hier ist nichts
gestützte der apparat
das ist echt scheiße mit diesem spiel
dingsda hier nämlich noch kurz ein
bisschen sand umbau dass hier wieder zu
ihr macht zwar erde mehr sind aber das
machen wir dann einfach in der nächsten
insel reparatur folge ich bin auf jeden
fall happy über das was wir geschafft
haben wir haben zwar hier rächt er noch
diesen kleinen raum hier müssen wir doch
zu machen hier drunter aber zumindest
das riesenloch unter meinem haus haben
wir zu das hat mich jeden tag ein
bisschen getriggert dass ich wusste dass
wir drunter nur hohlraum ist ja damit
würde ich die insel reparatur volk und
die generelle folge an der stelle ist
allerdings ob du was machst du denn
schon wieder hier ja besser so wenn es
euch gefallen hat er das gern einen
daumen hoch unter video hier da
vielleicht war ja euer kommentar und
eure frage heute auch mit drin wenn ihr
das video bis hingeschaut haben sollte
dann danke danke danke für euren
riesigen support abonniert main kanal
falls doch kein tabu sein und die
nächste minecraft mit luca episode
morgen nicht verpassen wollte story dass
dieses video eigentlich gestern kommen
sollte und gestern nicht gekommen ist
aber ich wusste nicht dass ich jetzt
zwei stunden lang insel reparatur
betreiber das ist die mit abstand
längste folge bisher aus diesem projekt
von daher hoffe ich es hat euch gefallen
ich hoffe es war nicht allzu langweilig
und die letzte wort hat der wille job
mach ich jetzt der typ nicht warten
[Musik]